welcome back america senator tom cotton
welcome thank you for being here i have
a question for you senator
you look at history you look at the you
look at athens you look at the roman
empire
they became weak from within and then of
course their enemies struck
and they collapsed we're only about 250
years old we're much younger than
athens and rome uh i see communist china
is on the rise
they have the intention of being the
most powerful country in the face the
earth they're spending a fortune on
their military
they're extremely aggressive
geopolitically
and then i see in our own country we're
really not providing enough resources to
the united states military
we are actually seeing some elements
within our media in the democrat party
who
are really propagandists for the
communist chinese
and then i watched our top brass uh
during a hearing
earlier this week embracing critical
race theory
and i don't believe they even understand
what critical race theory is it's a
marxist-based
theory there's simply no doubt about
that the
founders of critical race theory or
critical theory
they come out of this franklin school in
berlin they were communists they were
professors
and they brag about it so i'm just
wondering
i feel like we're getting weaker from
within and i'm not talking about the
uh the rank and file military i'm
talking about our leadership
while the communist chinese are getting
increasingly aggressive i'm concerned
about it do i have reason to be
concerned well mark i think we always
have reason to be concerned about the
future of america ronald reagan
like to say that future was never more
than one generation away from extinction
as you cite we're only 250 years old
compared to some of the great
republics and empires of human history i
want to make sure that we thrive for
another 250 years and more
that's one reason why i'm so concerned
about making sure that our
military is adequately funded which the
biden
budget does not do it cuts it in in real
terms after
dividing inflation but even if in just
straight up dollars it's so far below
what they're giving to say welfare
programs or other social spending
programs
that's why i'm worried about adding
another four trillion dollars
to our debt coming out of a once in a
century pandemic
adding public debt to the point where we
might not even be able to pay the debt
off
if interest rates go back to normal
these are very big consequential matters
now we have in the american people a
great resource
to defend our country to keep it
prosperous and free
but we need to have confidence in them
and i don't think enough democrats and
our leaders in washington have that
confidence in them
that's one reason why i've been speaking
out for instance in a hearing with
secretary lord austin a couple weeks ago
trying to pin him down on the fact that
no the military shouldn't be teaching
critical race theory they certainly
shouldn't be using it
in training sessions with frontline
privates and sergeants
and lieutenants they should focus on
tactics and operational excellence
the military needs to focus on real wars
not culture wars and you know it's
interesting senator the military
was really the first to integrate when
it comes to the federal government
uh it's always been ahead of the curve
when it comes to race and when it comes
to
treating military personnel as
individuals i mean every every
institution has its imperfections and
even its huge problems
throughout history but i'm saying as
people came to grips with racism the
military was among the first
institutions to come to grips with it
now you served in the military
uh extraordinarily brave soldier as you
were
did you find rampant white supremacy in
the military when you were serving there
no not at all mark and you're right that
the military uh
was one of the first major institutions
in american society
to integrate in the 1940s right
alongside
major league baseball with jackie
robinson and those who came after him
and it's been a place for the last 70
years
where americans of all backgrounds
of all races whether they're rich or
poor no matter who their parents are
can join and be judged solely on the
content of their character
not all those other factors just on how
you perform
whether you're in basic training or
officer candidate school
or out on the front lines in combat you
know they had a saying when i was in the
military talking about the ramp
of a bradley fighting vehicle when the
ramp
drops the bs stops because once that
ramp drops
and you deploy from your fighting
vehicle to start fighting the enemy
there's no more time for talk or for
boasting or anything else
than judging everyone based solely on
their performance and their skill
and their bravery and all of the
soldiers whom i served
they did not see each other as you know
from the north or the south
black white hispanic rich poor they saw
each other
as a battle buddy a comrade in arms who
were they
they were fighting alongside and they
were willing to lay down their life
to save another life that's what we
should want everyone
of our troopers to see when they look to
their left and right and their front and
rear
that's why it's so corrosive to try to
indoctrinate our troops in the front
line as i've heard from some of these
whistleblower complaints to my office
with the notions of critical race theory
that somehow some races
are inherently oppressive or privileged
or other races are inherently
victimized or oppressed the military
again
does not need to fight culture wars it
needs to focus
on fighting real wars and senator last
time i checked we've had the military in
afghanistan we've had the military in
iraq
we've had the military in the continent
of africa
we've had the military in southeast asia
most of these places last time i checked
are not majority white
and the fact of the matter is there is a
fable there is a fiction there is a big
lie that's being told about this country
and about the united states military and
what we are about and what we do
we'll be right back hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it
anywhere else